le décor et puis après permettre des
échanges avec les deux rapporteurs vous
dire que la délégation a adopté ce matin
donc ce rapport sénatorial que nous
avons lancé mettons il y a quelques mois
et qui a été confié à Gisèle Jourda et
Viviane Mallet
elles ont procédé respectivement à peu
près à 58 auditions 92 heures d'audition
158 personnes auditionnées donc on a
couvert quasiment pas quasiment
l'intégralité des acteurs de la filière
déchets en outre-mer et au plan national
et je pense notamment aux éco-organismes
et elles y reviendront avec trois
déplacements ça faisait longtemps que
pas les garçons de c'était pas déplacé
Crisco vie d'oblige et donc il était
important que sur un sujet comme
celui-là ou la réalité on la touche
encore plus quand on se déplace en nos
territoires les rapporteurs se sont donc
déplacés avec la délégation donc à la
à Mayotte tu as la Réunion et à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon ce qui permet
d'avoir une vue sur le terrain et de
rencontrer les acteurs en particulier on
a également opéré des tables rondes
thématiques par bassin ce qui nous a
permis de couvrir l'ensemble de
territoires ce qui fait de ce rapport
vraiment un travail un travail qui a été
demandé déjà depuis quelques années
maintenant Viviane Malley était porteuse
de ce message également au sein d'un
délégation depuis maintenant de
nombreuses années mais elle porte le
dossier dans l'hémicycle régulièrement
et elle en parlera mieux que moi tout à
l'heure et c'est vrai que ça fait de ce
rapport un rapport très exhaustif qui
couvre l'intégralité de l'outre-mer et
de manière très précise par territoire
ce qui nous donne très très bonne
photographie avec des données quand même
qui qui nous laissent penser le titre du
rapport le parle de à lui tout seul
puisqu'on parle de code d'alerte donc je
laisserai également les rapporteurs
pouvoir s'exprimer sur sur le sujet avec
une situation d'urgence immédiate
sanitaire environnementale et puis un
deuxième temps un temps long qui
nécessite un certain nombre de
préconisations donc ce sont les 26
recommandations qui font l'objet ce
rapport articuler entre nos deux carats
corrapeur donc je vais peut-être
maintenant laisser la parole alors je
sais pas si on passe d'abord aux
échanges avec vous pour que ce soit plus
interactif ou si les rapporteurs veulent
faire un exposé rapide de leur de leur
rapport comme comme vous le voulez on
est entre vos mains pour que ce soit le
plus
le plus utile également pour vous
et ben je vais peut-être laisser la
parole à vie viens peut-être pour
commencer
bon merci monsieur le Président bonjour
mesdames et messieurs merci d'être
présent donc effectivement comme vient
de souligner notre président après de
nombreusesions près de 160 personnes
auditionnées ou rencontrées trois
territoires visités
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon Mayotte et la
réunion
nous avons
nous allons proposer nous avons proposé
ce matin le rapport à la délégation
sénatoriale alors pourquoi ce sujet en
fait parce que la gestion des déchets
est un service public essentiel au cœur
du quotidien des populations au même
titre que l'eau ou l'assainissement et
sans lequel il ne peut avoir de
développement harmonieux et digne son
nos territoires alors cette réalité
confort et confirmée chaque jour la
question des déchets est au coeur de
l'actualité des Outre-mer pratiquement
pas un jour sans que la presse régionale
Ultramar et je vois le quotidien notre
qui est présent là ce matin donc c'est
vrai que la presse fait écho
régulièrement des problèmes des déchets
et nous avons aussi beaucoup
d'initiatives citoyennes des projets
innovants des problèmes de collecte de
traitement des déchets depuis sa société
civile et de moins en moins tolérante la
prise de conscience monte et les
collectifs citoyens se mobilisent de
plus en plus il y a une vraie crainte
pour le cadre de vie l'environnement et
le sentiment qu'on abîme nos territoires
le rapport est concentré sur les
spécificités ultramarines passent sur la
Politique des déchets en général tous
les déchets ont été évoqués mais avec
une attention particulière pour les
déchets ménagers alors le constat est
celui d'un retard majeur des Outre-mer
en matière de gestion des déchets tous
les territoires sont concernés mais à
des degrés très différents alors c'est
vrai que nous avons le problématique de
l'environnement nous avons le
problématique de l'éloignement nous
avons le problématique aussi de nos
modes de vie
qui sont très différents d'un territoire
à l'autre mais bon c'est surtout
l'éloignement qu'il faut
et la géographie qu'il faut retenir un
chiffre en métropole à environ 15% des
déchets ménagers finissent dans les
centres d'enfouissement 85 étant
valoriser autrement le rapport est
inversé en Martinique qui est le
territoire ultramarin qui enfouit le
moins ce taux d'enfouissement et de 40%
environ en 2020 quand les autres se
situent entre 60 et 80%, voire même 100%
à Mayotte alors sur la collecte
sélective les ratios sont aussi très
faibles par rapport à l'Hexagone les
emballages ménagers en des taux de 3 à 4
fois inférieur voire 20 fois comme un
Mayotte d'autres filières rebs sont même
absentes de certains des territoires où
viennent juste de s'y implanter par
exemple la filière ameublement à Mayotte
et en Guyane n'existe pas très
clairement les écho-organismes ont
longtemps négligé des Outre-mer
cela coûté trop cher et c'était
compliqué et c'est que depuis trois ou
quatre ans et surtout depuis le vote de
la loi à Jacques largement monté par le
Sénat que les écho-organismes se
penchent sérieusement sur ces
territoires alors un autre point
saillant une part importante des flux
échappe à la collecte par exemple en
Guyane et à Mayotte les quartiers
informels peuvent représenter jusqu'à
41% de la population le service de
collecte
ni
va pas et les habitants ne contribuent
pas au service public en fait il y a le
fléau des dépôts sauvages jusqu'à 1200
recensés à la Réunion par exemple par la
RS plus de 300 en Martinique et pour les
VHU abandonnés le stock historique
estimé à 65000 en 2015 n'aurait diminué
que d'un tiers en 7 ans après pourtant
un plan très spécial ce tableau
défiances et retarde de la gestion des
déchets outre-mer place et territoires
dans la situation d'urgence
environnementale mais aussi et surtout
d'urgence sanitaire le constat est
alarmant en Guyane et à Mayotte à
Mayotte des enfants jouent dans les
dépotoirs comme nous avons pu le
constater cette situation exige de faire
et d'en faire une cause nationale et
comme dirait dans ma cooporterie un plan
machin pour Mayotte elle lit tient
beaucoup alors un exemple très concret
des conséquences sanitaires graves la
leptospirose par exemple qui peut être
mortelle et nettement favorisée par
l'abandon de déchets et la prolifération
des rats en Guyane son taux de
prévalence et 70 fois supérieur à celui
de la France hexagonale il peut y avoir
aussi le problème des anciennes
décharges illégales qui peuvent polluer
les sols l'eau très longuement après
leur fermeture alors un suivi évidemment
est nécessaire les enjeux
environnementaux sont forts sans qu'il
soit besoin d'en dire plus pourra faire
l'outre-mer héberge 80% de la
biodiversité
cela appelle un effort national à la
hauteur de la responsabilité de la
France pour défendre cette biodiversité
mais aussi c'est un enjeu économique pas
de touriste possible si le paysage
s'entend étant l'édit très clairement la
côte d'alerte est atteinte voire
dépasser dans certains territoires en
état des lieux et a été fait par
territoire des différenciations
importantes existent la situation de
chaque territoire pour être résumé ainsi
Mayotte et la Guyane sont en Argence
absolue comme on l'a déjà dit tout reste
à construire à titre d'exemple il n'y a
pas de déchets tri en Mayotte c'est
prévu mais pas encore d'actualité pour
l'instant et seulement deux en Guyane
pour un territoire grand comme le
Portugal la Guadeloupe et la Martinique
et la police en française sont sur une
ligne de crête et ne parviennent pas à
accélérer l'urgence et gérer mes pas
au-delà
est en train de bouger avec un essor du
tri sélectif et des dépotoirs sauvages
en vue en voie de réception la Réunion
la Nouvelle-Calédonie sont mieux engagés
faire un changement de modèle avec de
meilleures infrastructures en
particulier à la réunion avec de grands
projets en construction Saint-Barthélemy
est à part avec une bonne gestion
moderne mais une absence de prévention
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et le bon élève
de la prévention et du tri mais
complètement défaillant sur le
traitement avec des décharges littorales
illégales qui brûlent un ciel ouvert
saint-pierre-et-miquel excusez-moi par
ailleurs il faut souligner la fragilité
financière du service public des déchets
le coût de gestion outre-mer est en
moyenne 1,7 + élevé qu'en métropole pas
les recettes rentrent mal le taux de la
théom sont déjà élevés près du tout de
la moyenne nationale surtout la théorème
est perçue avec la taxe foncière or
cette taxe est très mal collectée dans
les outre-mer notamment en raison de
l'inactitude du cadastre et beaucoup de
syndicats mixtes sont avec des finances
très fragiles
alors le défi pour les êtres humains et
donc double bon il y a un écho
du départ j'irai d'urgence avec des
actions rapides
je pense que c'est bon je vais continuer
donc les défis comme je te disais pour
les outre-mer et donc double d'une part
gérer l'urgence avec des actions rapides
des investissements structurants
classiques d'autre part s'engager sur la
voie de l'économie circulaire qui est
souvent un chemin très long
via mais bien plus durable alors
l'équilibre est difficile à trouver et
nous avons 26 propositions du rapport
qui s'y est forcent seront de répondre à
ses problématiques et ma Gisèle Vanda va
vous les présenter merci de votre
attention
donc merci beaucoup Viviane donc et
merci mesdames et messieurs de votre
présence qui témoigne de l'intérêt que
vous portez donc à ce sujet d'importance
qui est la collecte le traitement et la
valorisation des déchets dans les
départements
ultramarins 26 propositions elles vous
ont été distribuées je n'en évoquerai
qu'une dizaine pour pouvoir pré laisser
place aux questions
on l'a dit côte d'alerte urgence
que mettre en place par rapport à la
situation d'abord des plans de
rattrapage exceptionnel se doivent être
mises en place ainsi qu'un puissant
ballon d'oxygène financier pour ces
territoires
pour investir nous proposons donc un
plan d'exceptionnel de 250 millions
d'euros sur 5 ans
étant bien entendu que ces fonds
s'ajoutent au fond existant
c'est une important ensuite ma collègue
l'a évoqué deux territoires à l'énorme
difficulté Mayotte et la Guyane et pour
Mayotte effectivement un plan Marshall
XXL
s'impose parce que la situation ni
absolument pas tenable tant à mentir
donc de
déchets que de décharge et que du vécu
au quotidien et que des vecteurs donc de
maladies qui donc sont générés par cette
situation très clairement il s'agit de
doter ces territoires d'un vrai réseau
de déchetterie de centre de tri et
d'unités de valorisation énergétique
les centres d'enfouissement seront aussi
mis aux normes
autre mesure très forte de notre rapport
et une mesure
qui a donc une marraine et vraiment une
personne qui le porte énormément c'est
l'exonération de la TGAP pour
synchronisant dossier cher à Madame
Viviane Mallet cette taxe est injuste
inefficace à notre mère chaque année les
contestée et rabotée lors de l'examen de
la loi de finance pourtant malgré ses
réactions sont coups pour les
collectivités ne cesse de s'alourdir la
TGAP représente déjà 16% des budgets de
fonctionnement et si rien n'est fait
elle va doubler
cette mesure d'exonération permettra
d'alléger massivement immédiatement les
dépenses de fonctionnement des syndicats
mixtes et des EPCI résultat tout de
suite cela permet de renforcer
l'ingénierie en recrutant de renforcer
la collecte la prévention la
communication et surtout de réinvestir
en 2020 la TGAP a coûté 17 millions
d'euros sur cinq ans ces près de 100
millions d'euros réinjectés pour les
déchets dans les sols
alors là je tiens à le souligner je ne
veux pas être lourde sur ce sujet mais
vraiment
vous avez un Viviane Mallet quelqu'un
qui a d'abord nous avons constaté sur
les territoires que c'était unanimement
portée lorsque nous nous avons fait donc
notre rapport c'est quelque chose qui
est commun il ne demande qui est portée
par tous mais à un certain moment donné
il faut quelqu'un qu'il incarne et c'est
énormément incarné donc par par Viviane
qui tient qui a à cœur donc de faire que
cette mesure soit mise en place afin
qu'on puisse progresser
alors bien sûr que d'autres rapports
proposent d'autres mesures
dans les collectivités d'outre-mer le
modèle de l'écotaxe
valisienne est très intéressant sur la
gouvernance c'est très important la
gouvernance il est ressorti de nos
auditions
un manque de vision globale dans
certains territoires avec plusieurs
acteurs en charge du traitement aussi
bien dans certains drones que dans les
collectivités d'outre-mer même si les
organisations diffèrent dans chaque
territoire ce qui est tout à fait
logique puisqu'ils ne sont pas tous
dans la même parité donc
institutionnelle
il faut aller vers un opérateur unique
pour assurer le traitement dans les
dromes un seul syndicat mixte serait la
bonne solution comme cela existe en
Martinique ou à Mayotte
indépendamment des difficultés propres
de ces établissements bien sûr en
Polynésie le pays doit récupérer la
compétence assumée par des communes qui
sont totalement dépourvues de moyenne
c'est une mesure donc phare qui nous a
été inspiré donc par Monsieur tétouani
parce que compte tenu des écarts et des
distances il n'est pas possible de de
continuer dans ce type de gouvernance en
Nouvelle-Calédonie il faut simplifier le
millefeuille gouvernement province et
commune
une meilleure coordination fait défaut
la région est en charge d'élaborer le
plan régional de prévention et de
gestion des déchets mais ensuite ce qui
fait des faux c'est le suivi il y a un
défaut complet de suivi et il n'y a pas
de coordination et le pilotage est donc
totalement irrégulier il faut donc le
comité du suivi du plan
deviennent une véritable instance de
pilotage et de coordination surtout
excusez-moi surtout sur les territoires
insulaires et quand il dit territoire
insulaire ça peut être la double triple
insularité tous les acteurs ont besoin
d'être au diapason il faut éviter les
doublons sur les projets de recyclage
ensuite
qu'est-ce que nous avons constaté le
problème qu'il y a l'ingénierie à
l'expertise ça n'est pas donc
une réalité égale sur l'ensemble des
territoires et franchement c'est là donc
une question qui est qui va au-delà
d'ailleurs de notre rapport toutefois
pour que le plan exceptionnel des 250
milieux d'euros sur 50 je vous ai parlé
soit réellement consommée nous proposons
que dans chaque territoire il y ait des
plateformes de projet
regroupant l'ingénierie d'État les
l'État et les collectivités comme ça
donc ça permet de créer une base où les
projets prendront encore d'autres
mesures sont proposées comme la mise en
place d'un guichet unique pour les
collectivités ou leur renforcement du
fond outre-mer géré par l'AFD il a
témoigné de toute son efficacité
alors maintenant
on va parler de quelque chose qui nous a
particulièrement donc surprise
et fortement interrogé c'est ce que nous
avons appelé et que nous a pas que l'on
la carence des échos organismes qui
commencent seulement à s'investir ces
sérieusement dans ces territoires le
temps de l'obligation de résultats est
venu nous proposons
que si des résultats ne viennent pas
s'éterner et bien il va falloir expirer
biener des pénalités automatiques pour
les écho-organismes qui n'atteignent pas
les objectifs chiffrés
il faut enfin que les cahiers des
charges des filières auraient prennent
mieux en compte les outre-mer
les filières au REP ne peuvent pas se
cacher derrière leur petit doigt et
effectivement
a priori quelqu'un de la Direction de
l'action
[Musique]
alors
oui
donc je disais que les
il faut enfin que les cahiers des
charges les filières prennent mieux en
compte les outre-mer car c'est
totalement insuffisant on a bien vu que
et je le disais il ne faut pas qu'il se
cache derrière leur petit doigt c'est
que quand on peut entendre que pour ces
filières repent certaines trouvent
qu'évidemment dans les départements
ultramarins donc c'est beaucoup plus
cher que les filières reêpes donc en
hexagone c'est pas entendable il faut
que ces filières soient mises en place
dans les départements ultramarins comme
d'ailleurs donc la législation leur en
fait obligation
dont les échos organismes doivent
mutualiser leurs moyens et non pas agir
chacun dans leur couloir les cahiers des
charges doivent l'imposer
les précédentes propositions visent à
insuffler une nouvelle dynamique avec
plus de financement une meilleure
gouvernance de l'ingénierie et des
éco-organismes investis elles doivent
doter les acteurs du déchet des moyens
d'agir donc pour ce faire nous avons
prévu une seconde série de propositions
qui elles concerne davantage les
stratégies de mise en place à déployer
pour entamer un virage vers davantage
d'économie circulaire dans le contexte
particulier des Outre-mer
un point important il faut adapter la
réglementation si nous n'adâtons pas la
réglementation nous aurons toujours ces
temps de retard à combler et nous aurons
toujours ces disparités entre
territoires et au sein même d'ailleurs
de certaines territoires parce que dans
des régions même il y a des disparités
qu'on soit au nord au sud ou à l'est
c'est pas du tout les mêmes
problématiques
donc nous proposons aussi quatre titres
mental les outre-mer soit habilités à
fixer leur propre normes à matière
d'interdiction de mise sur le Parchis de
certains produits de réemploi ou de
consignes
la consigne sur le verre peut ainsi
avoir un grand avenir comme c'est le cas
à la Réunion où elle est donc est mise
en place
et expérimenter la réglementation est un
levier
à mieux exploiter elle doit définir la
prévention en réduisant ou supprimant
certains produits particulièrement
difficile à traiter sur ces territoires
des systèmes de consignes sur les
batteries seraient intéressant à
expérimenter pour qu'elle cessent de
finir au bout de des routes et dans les
ravines et comme le disait donc Viviane
dans la partie constat il est hors de
question de voir ses batteries qui sont
extrêmement dangereuses être finalement
soit des sortes de Gai dans des passages
donc de de
usées ou joue les enfants à proximité au
risque de pouvoir être contaminés c'est
quand même quelque chose là de
d'extrêmement d'un prégnant dans les
territoires isolés et les plus
défavorisés
une piste prometteuse est à développer
ce sont les dispositifs de gratification
du tri alors là il y a une expérience à
Mayotte qui mérite donc d'être souligné
tout comme d'ailleurs à Wallis
alors cette expérience a
à Mayotte bisous le fait de
gratifié donc les personnes qui vont
puisque la collecte est vraiment donc en
récession
visu à gratifier les personnes qui vont
déposer dans les magasins de proximité
ils vont déposer donc leurs déchets et
ils sont donc valorisés par des bons
d'achat c'est à dire que s'il amène des
déchets et bien ils ont en contrepartie
donc des bons pour des produits
d'hygiène etc etc et ça marche
extrêmement bien de même nous
préconisons donc la mise en place des
écocarbés que vous allez me dire kézako
les écocarbées bien ce sont des sortes
de centres d'un fuis seulement simplifié
qui ont montré de très bons résultats en
Guyane et dans les visages isolés cette
expérience pourrait inspirer d'autres
projets par exemple dans les îles
polynésiennes
autre sujet majeur qui a été évoqué par
Viviane Mallet tout à l'heure c'est
celui du fléau des dépôts sauvages des
peaux sauvages qui sont dont générateur
donc de pollution tant des sols de
pollution des nappes phréatiques mais
surtout vecteurs et porteur de maladies
sur ce point notre constat
un de nos constats aimer le ce qui est
vraiment le plus prégnant c'est que la
répression dans ce domaine est beaucoup
trop faible
la loi était complexe mais depuis la loi
GEC de 2020 les moyennes légaux ont été
renforcés et clarifiés ce pourquoi nous
proposons de la création de police
municipale intercommunale concentré sur
la lutte contre les dépôts sauvages et
ces brigades de 22 de police municipale
de doivent être créés à notre sens
partout sur les territoires ou existent
ces décharges
entre levier possible je reviens aux
éco-organismes la loi agent mais à la
charge des échos organismes le coût du
nettoiement des dépôts mais à partir de
100 tonnes ce seuil est beaucoup trop
élevé nous demandons qu'ils soient
baissé c'est urgent il faut l'abaisser
de manière drastique à une tonne par
exemple il est évident que le seuil est
à discuter il y a d'autres partenaires
qui travaillent sur ces sujets nous
sommes nous sur un sujet transversal et
nous sommes la sonnette d'alarme
d'Angers de cette côte d'alerte mais
nous sommes ouverts à des partenariats
dans ce domaine j'en viens à un point
très important qui est celui de donner
beaucoup plus d'importance aux filières
locales de recyclage
alors elles sont développées dans
certains territoires et elles sont
complètement inexistantes dans d'autres
ce qui n'empêche pas qu'il nous avons
constaté de visu un foisonnement de
projet et des premières réalisations
d'envergure comme le recyclage du plâtre
donc et du vert à la Réunion qui est
vraiment donc exemplaire moi je dois
dire qui est vraiment à suivre
sur tous les territoires il y a
l'ambition et des projets ce monde c'est
l'axe majeur à soutenir dans les
prochaines années pour sortir de la
logique de l'exportation alors là c'est
vraiment un point très très donc
qui moi en tant qu'hexagonale m'a
énormément choqué c'est le transport des
déchets
qu'on n'arrive pas à donc à faire sortir
des territoires ultramarins pour
certains ils sont contraints de par le
côté insulaire il n'y a pas d'autres
possibilités c'est stocké et ensuite il
y a l'évacuation de ces déchets qui peut
pas se faire parce que bien souvent il
traverse plusieurs zones avec des zones
douanières différentes et certains zones
ne veulent pas de certains produits et
on a des containers qui attendent de
partir depuis des mois et des mois et
qui n'arrivent pas donc à circuler ça
c'est vraiment un gros gros problème
donc pour notamment pour les déchets
dangereux ou qui reviennent comme le dit
et qui reviennent et ça c'est quand même
un gros un gros problème
nous n'avons pas de solution clé en main
sur ce sujet mais nous ne sommes pas ni
l'une ni l'autre des petites fées avec
une baguette magique mais en tout cas
nous avons des baguettes magiques pour
en tout cas réveiller les consciences et
ça je crois que c'est extrêmement
important et même si ça te va demander
patience mais cette multitude d'actions
il faut les commencer par un soutien
financier au projet
quelques pistes se dégagent mieux
partager les expériences entre les
outre-mer pour les dupliquer renforcer
la défiscalisation structurer les
écopoles autour des centres de tri
multifilaire et fixer aux échos
organismes des objectifs de recyclage
local
notre dernier axe fort si la
valorisation énergétique des déchets à
ce jour seul la Martinique et
Saint-Barthélémy pardon on a tellement
l'habitude de dire Saint-Barth
et c'est Barthélémy on recourt à
métropole cela représente 30% des
déchets ménagers c'est nécessaire si on
veut réduire rapidement l'enfouissement
et valoriser les déchets qui aujourd'hui
à l'état des technologies et des
capacités des territoires ne peuvent pas
être encore recyclés pour cela il faut
que la Commission de régulation de
l'énergie définit son cadre clair
pérenne et favorable au prix de rachat
de l'électricité produite par
l'incinération des déchets l'équilibre
économique de ces projets en dépend les
déchets peuvent compléter le mix
énergétique des Outre-mer qui doivent
tendre vers l'autonomie voilà les
on nous lavande décliné qu'une dizaine
de propositions mais vous dire que notre
volonté conjointe a été de dresser un
état des lieux et de dresser des
perspectives pour en sortir et
aujourd'hui l'urgence a sorti est
extrêmement importantes vous trouverez
dans le rapport par territoire quel que
soit la qualification et en tout cas
institutionnelle et l'histoire
institutionnelle des territoires vous
trouverez
l'exhaustivité de toutes les auditions
auxquelles nous avons proposé et surtout
vous pouvez vous pourrez repérer sur
chacun des territoires voulus les
discussions qui sont générées par les
territoires et nous en avons fait non
pas la substantifique moellement en tout
cas nous avons essayé de dresser à la
fois constat et piste pour pouvoir donc
ouvrir la discussion et je laisse le
soin à Viviane de conclure
précarité de certains territoires et
puis l'urgence absolue à agir vous
l'avez compris
c'est une cause pour nous nationale qui
mérite que la solidarité nationale joue
pleinement nous avons ces 27
propositions sont aussi concrètes que
possible et appelle des traductions
précises soit par le lot par la loi soit
par le règlement ou des mesures
administratives alors le travail avec le
groupe d'études sur l'économie
circulaire permettra certainement de
faire fructifier certaines d'entre elles
notamment lors des débats en séance
publique voilà Mesdames et Messieurs
le projet le rapport que nous avons
soumis ce matin à la délégation des
Outre-mer merci donc nous sommes à votre
disposition pour
pour des questions
plébiscité publicité oui il dit vous
dire également que sur la base des
préconisations d'un rapport de Pascal
Grigny au Sénat en fait le Sénat adopté
un nouveau dispositif étant de suivi de
ces travaux notamment au niveau des
rapports ce qui explique qu'en réalité
on identifie les leviers qui soient
législatif ou réglementaires le
calendrier dans lequel ils peuvent se
réaliser et quels sont les acteurs qui
vont être mis en oeuvre donc ça va
permettre de donner de la visibilité
aussi aux acteurs et aux législateur et
y compris à l'action de contrôle que
nous avons notamment sur la partie
gouvernementale ici dans cette maison et
parce que les gens nous disent souvent
mais que deviennent vos rapports enfin
ils ont un suivi en l'occurrence et là
l'objectif du Sénat c'est de donner de
la visibilité y compris aux journalistes
que vous êtes puisque vous pourrez
également suivre les avancées
successives et on sait déjà que le
groupe de travail économie circulaire va
se faire le porte-voix d'un certain
nombre de recommandations d'ailleurs
Gisèle on fait partie également donc
voilà il y aura par capillarité ça va
remonter dans différentes commissions et
institution du Sénat et donc le rôle de
la délégation ce sera évidemment
d'assurer le suivi de ces
recommandations pour avoir un peu à quel
échéance c'est dans quelles conditions
elles peuvent se mettre en œuvre
et nous sommes à votre disposition bien
évidemment
j'avais peut-être une question pour je
travaille pour RCI Nicolas Ledent de
radio des Antilles
je voulais savoir vous parler de
gradification du tri notamment est-ce
que vous avez identifié des besoins de
sensibilisation peut-être à mener auprès
des populations c'est qu'il y a des
habitudes locales parfois qui sont très
ancrés sur la gestion des déchets au
quotidien
oui nous avons donc constaté sur les
territoires d'abord des plans de
communication certains c'est zéro déchet
par exemple c'était quelque chose de
très important les sensibilisations dont
des populations on a pu voir la
sensibilisation des scolaires qui sont
mises donc en place mais là aussi à un
certain moment donné
il y a des territoires mais ça
plus avancé que d'autres sur certains
secteurs parce que là où se pratiquent
les collectes c'est ça qu'il faut bien
comprendre là où la collecte est donc
assurée je pense notamment à la Réunion
là où le traitement est assuré comme à
la Réunion il y a des plans de
communication de sensibilisation qui ont
été mis en place pour en arriver après
donc à la valorisation du déchet mais
vous avez certaines territoires où la
collecte la simple collecte n'est pas
mise en place non pas parce qu'il y a
pas il y a une volonté de d'empêcher
par exemple à Mayotte
de Mayotte le tri sélectif les bornes
sélectives verts cartons tout ça comment
ça à s'implanter sur le territoire et
dans une dans un thé dans une mairie ou
un territoire on a vu sur Mayotte par
exemple une disait que les bornes de
réceptionner que 40 kg à la fin de
l'année quoi c'est en fait la population
n'est pas habituée on n'a pas ce réflexe
d'amener ou n'a pas peut-être le
transport aussi pour l'amener c'est ça
aussi la difficulté
s'agissant des maîtrises d'ouvrages des
projets vous avez parlé des syndicats
mixtes est-ce que les entreprises
publiques locales sont aussi une source
de projets potentiels et facilitant dans
la mesure où elles peuvent associer les
énergies et les moyens du public et du
privé et où il y a semble-t-il aussi un
contexte favorable on a vu de au Congrès
des SEM que au dernier congrès des
entreprises publiques locales à Tours
que les le mouvement de des Epl
d'outre-mer prend prendre la vigueur ça
c'est une première question puis une
deuxième question est-ce que vous avez
calculé les besoins d'investissement
cumulé
qui qui serait nécessaire pour combler
le retard que vous avez constaté oui je
suis Laurent Miguet du moniteur des
travaux publics et du bâtiment
alors
sur la maîtrise d'ouvrage je vais
répondre sur l'aspect un peu technique
et juridique
si vous allez sur les EPL en particulier
vous savez que une PL n'aura pas
vocation à gérer la fiscalité ou la taxe
liée aux ordures ménagères puisque
contrairement au syndicats qui lui se
voit conférer la compétence contre une
collectivité adhère par exemple une
commune adhère un syndicat mixte fermée
ou ouvert il y a un transfert de
compétences et un transfert de la
fiscalité sur les EPL on n'a pas le même
dispositif ce qui fait que la fiscalité
reste à nouveau commune je presque envie
de vous dire que si on parle de maîtrise
d'ouvrage de la construction
d'infrastructures comme sont les poches
d'enfouissement qu'on a pu évoquer
notamment et qui existe par exemple à la
Réunion et que que connaît bien Viviane
effectivement maîtrise d'ouvrage des
collectivités ont peut-être intérêt à
déléguer cette maîtrise d'ouvrage assez
EPL qui ont la compétence de
savoir-faire et l'ingénierie qui
évoquait Gisèle au regard des réseaux
des réseaux existants sur la gestion en
tant que tel en fait la réflexion de la
dé c'est plutôt de se dire de
rationaliser peut-être et d'avoir un
seul opérateur en fonction du type de
déchet et en l'occurrence on parlait du
déchets ménagers
peut-être sur la partie sur les déchets
donc des entreprises
moi ce qui m'a énormément frappé
puisque c'est vrai que
dans l'Hexagone on voit les différentes
filières mais c'est quand un certain
moment donné par rapport à tout ce qui
est donc déchets du bâtiment donc
valorisation donc de de ces déchets
création de filières etc
sur dans certains secteurs il y a les
entreprises qui commencent à
s'emparer de la problématique mais
je suis vraiment navrée de dire que
c'est pas pour tout ce quoi et c'est des
charges et puis comme valorise qu'on
valorise pas on en est plus là donc
c'est vraiment donc
au tout départ de la chaîne et ça moi ça
m'a énormément choquée parce que quand
on voit comment aujourd'hui on peut
valoriser des déchets en fer ce qu'on
dit dans notre rapport une ressource en
fait supplémentaire pour les territoires
je crois que là comme Monsieur parler
tout à l'heure d'avoir une démarche
pédagogique qui va falloir avoir une
démarche pour pouvoir donc sens réaliser
les entreprises à se saisir des
problématiques en matière donc de
recyclage de traitement de leur propre
déchets il n'y aura à leur activité
et les SPL aménagement par exemple vous
avez aussi toute une partie moi je vois
la Réunion qui est
ciblée pour tout ce qui est recyclage
voilà pour que les installations se
placent s'installe et que le recyclage
se fasse avec les entreprises donc
c'était c'était des poches dédiées à
l'environnement
qui a bien un partenariat public cuivré
utilisé et aussi le vert qui sert de
Lyon pour le chapes de béton et aussi
une technique aussi innovante c'est le
broyage du verre pour les recyclages de
piscine à place de mettre du sable
et alors sur le cumul d'investissement
nécessaire
on a donné par année et par je crois que
tu as donné le
pour tenter c'est ce que je m'exprimer
on a chiffré ça à 250 millions d'euros
sur 50 et comme je l'ai dit venant
des crédits et des sources de
financement actuelles par rapport si
vous voulez je pense qu'on est peut-être
en dessous même de de la jauge voulue
mais il fallait un moment fixer quelque
chose parce que c'est très
bon j'exprime non pas la difficulté que
je ressentis parce que c'est c'est un
sujet qui est passionnant mais il y a
tellement de de de choses à remettre à
parité
c'est vraiment une scie sur cinq ans on
arrivait à l'Isser 250 millions d'euros
je pense que pour certains territoires
avancés on va en faire donc
l'exemplarité comme nous disions aussi
il y a il y a des expériences sur les
territoires dont on peut s'inspirer pour
les autres en sachant que nous avons
donc à mettre donc dans ce plan Marshall
quelque part dans ce plan d'urgence nous
devons quelque part consolider les plus
faibles plus faible c'est la Guyane et
ses Mayotte voilà et à si nous
n'arrivons pas donc à faire prendre
conscience au pouvoir public qu'il y a
maintenant il faut passer donc
des
constats aux actes
et les actes ça se marque par par le
fait d'additionner des dispositifs et si
on ne commence pas si on ne met pas le
pied à l'étrier ben on saura se
retrouver
donc dans quelques années dans la même
situation mais moi je tiens surtout à
sensibiliser sur le fait que nous
lorsque nous parlons du de problématique
de déchets de dispositifs législatif on
n'a pas
géoculté le le l'aspect européen parce
que là aussi nous nous devons par
rapport à la réglementation européenne
et nous le disons dans le rapport nous
nous devons de passer à une échelle
supérieure et avec Madame de Sidra qui
s'occupe donc de tout ce qui est
économie circulaire membre de la
commission des affaires européennes il y
a des dispositifs qu'on portera pour
faire évoluer et évoluer les
législations c'est un point extrêmement
important mais derrière ça on parle
d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants qui
vivent dans un quotid dont personne ne
voudrait plus et je rappelle que nous
sommes en France
on parle pas et cette problématique si
on ne la fait pas notre et si on ne
marque pas comme l'a dit donc Viviane là
maintenant il est urgent d'agir c'est
vraiment une question de survie
pour certains territoires parce que les
vecteur de maladie que ce soit la lève
post-cyrrose que ce soit bon ceux qui
communiquaient par les nuisibles par etc
c'est quand même extrêmement
les cas là il reste que nous avons
rencontré les cas sont endémiques
c'est-à-dire que d'une année sur l'autre
ils sont en constante évolution on ne
peut pas perdurer comme cela et ensuite
il y a comme pour tout projet comme pour
tout dossier et bien on pointe les
problématiques globales et général qui
sont des problématiques donc
vital pour ne pas dire viscérale et puis
après il y a ce que l'on peut aménager
parce qu'il y a eu des progrès qui ont
été réalisés il faut pas non plus
il faut il faut faire un constat qui
soit un Costa équitable voilà un peu moi
ce que je souhaitais renvoyer donc comme
[Musique]
visage donne sur sur ce rapport parce
que c'est vraiment quelque chose
un moment quand tu parles il y a des
années des années en arrière quand on a
eu conscience des problèmes de pollution
des problèmes d'environnement des
problèmes de comment mieux vivre dans
dans la nature parce que je vous parle
pas de la mangrove donc à Mayotte ou
donc de de
l'état des sols mais il y avait quelque
chose qui s'appelait la France des
figurés c'était une des premières
émissions qui étaient faites par un
journaliste qui voulait montrer comment
on pouvait défigurer donc un paysage ou
institutionnel et bien là on est sur des
départements
ultramarins pour certaines défigurés et
nous devons jouer on a tenté en tout cas
autour de notre président qui nous a
beaucoup soutenu avec Madame Mallet de
d'apporter un peu de de de
réponse en profondeur mais surtout
d'essayer de
de redonner un peu de l'harmonie assez
une harmonisation entre ces territoires
qui méritent vraiment d'être pris en
compte vous voulez remettre un point
aussi surtout faire très attention à la
réglementation européenne parce qu'il
faut pas non plus que cette
réglementation nous nous exclut parce
qu'en fait on a évolué c'est vrai en sur
l'hexagone et dans les pays européens
s'il vous plaît
avec actuellement c'est plutôt tout ce
qui est
ressourcerie
en fait mais nous on en est pas encore
là donc il faut faire très attention
qu'on ne soit pas exclu sur ses aides là
et qu'on fasse attention à nos
territoires
plus les exonérations de tgapération
je pense qu'on a tous senti que vraiment
le sujet vous tient à coeur et que ce
que vous avez vu sur ces différents
territoires vous en profondément marqué
on a bien compris également qu'il y
avait une urgence absolue un plan
Marshall XXL en tout cas moi ça m'a j'ai
retenu cette expression j'aimerais
savoir par rapport à l'importance de ce
rapport comment vous allez mettre en
place l'imagine une stratégie pour ne
pas que ce rapport finalement soit un
report parmi tant d'autres parce que des
rapports on en a eu énormément que ce
soit sur les déchets ou sur d'autres
sujets problématiques au niveau des
Outre-mer donc quel est votre stratégie
pour essayer que ce rapport finalement
aille le plus loin possible et pour que
les propositions que vous avez mis soit
entendu
le président
puisque nous avons un suivi au Sénat sur
les préconisations qui sont adoptées par
ce qui est un planning
et automatiquement dès qu'on va les
chiffres on va regarder
on l'a déjà fait là actuellement pour la
TGV puisque le rapport n'était pas
encore rendu mais on a quand même déposé
c'est vrai deux amendements pour
une réfraction supplémentaire pour
Guyane Martinique réunion qui a été
adopté au Sénat et notre sur une
un gel de la tigerp
donc en l'occurrence il y a toujours un
suivi de l'ensemble des rapports cette
fois-ci le suivi sera plus resserré ça
c'est une un nouveau dispositif
transversal à toutes les commissions et
délégations du Sénat aujourd'hui avec un
tableau de bord qui vous permettra
d'avoir une visibilité en a commencé
d'ailleurs pas un peu par anticipation
au mois de juillet sur notamment les
risques majeurs avec une audition de
contrôle du gouvernement et un tableau
synoptique qui traçait l'ensemble des
recommandations et l'état d'avancement
et les mesures mises en oeuvre donc ça
permet quand même d'assurer un suivi et
puis vous aurez à l'issue à la fin de ce
rapport effectivement merci Dina de me
le montrer ainsi effectivement le modèle
type de tableau de suivi tableau de bord
qui qui sera transversale à l'ensemble
des travaux du Sénat et qui nous
permettront régulièrement au sein de la
délégation et au sein de votre groupe de
vérifier dans quelle mesure les
dispositifs sont mis en oeuvre et
effectivement Viviane par anticipation
puisqu'elle porte ce sujet TGAP depuis
des années maintenant
ça a été suivi ça a été suivi et voilà
le rapport s'inscrit dans cette
filiation c'est pas dans la navette qui
deviendra simplement vous dire que donc
d'abord notre délégation je le dis parce
qu'on ne l'a pas exprimé elle est moitié
composée par vos sénateurs
ultramarins et par des sénateurs
hexagonaux parce que donc la France elle
est
composite et le tout de la France c'est
l'ensemble de ces départements et
simplement dire que cette délégation j'y
appartient depuis 8 ans il y a 8 ans que
je suis au Sénat c'est une délégation
passionnante parce que quelque part
comme dit la pub elle ne lâche rien
c'est-à-dire que lorsque nous émettons
des rapports c'est pas faire un rapport
pour un rapport c'est que même avant que
notre vie ce présidente madame grenier
veuille resserré donc la chose et avoir
un tableau de bord de suivi ce qui est
une excellente chose les sénateurs
ultramarins lorsqu'il y a un rapport qui
a été fait n'en avait fait sur le sucre
pour la Réunion j'avais donc porter moi
à la commission des affaires européennes
le fait de de minimiser l'accord avec le
Vietnam qu'on a fait tomber parce que
sinon on plombé la filière c'était
extrêmement dangereux il y a eu un
rapport sur le sport on a fait passer
des amendements il y a eu donc le
rapport évoqué par notre président dont
là aujourd'hui on est passé sur une
autre phase parce que
[Musique]
plus belle là-dessus pour tenter de
porter ses problématiques et voilà c'est
pour répondre en complément madame à
votre questionnement je crois que
Monsieur fontaine qui est en
visioconférence vous voulez nous poser
une question monsieur fontaine
bon écoutez ce n'est pas le cas
en tout cas nous sommes à votre
disposition si vous n'avez pas d'autres
questions je propose de lever cette
conférence de presse et puis n'hésitez
pas à entretenir les liens nécessaires
pour que nous puissions continuer à vous
abreuver à nous abreuver de des
réflexions qui ont été celles de la
délégation tout au long de ce travail et
qui vont évidemment se poursuivre
maintenant dans les mois qui viennent en
tout cas merci de votre disponibilités
de votre présence pardon ah Monsieur
Fontaine
a envoyé la question
difficile aussi déréglementation
nationale et européenne par exemple le
tri obligatoire des biodéchets à horizon
2024 les territoires d'outre-mer
sont-ils en capacité d'appliquer cette
mesure donc sur les biodéchets
on l'a pointé ce matin dans le rapport
oui très clairement oui et je crois pas
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait que
outre-mer qui ne sera pas en capacité de
mettre en œuvre cette réglementation
début 2020 on en reparlera je pense au
niveau national et à plus forte raison
en outre-mer pour des raisons de
distance d'éparpillement et de
géographie parfois de nos territoires et
donc je pense que le principe de réalité
voudrait effectivement qu'on puisse
adapter et c'est ce qu'on appelle nous
la délégation un terme qu'on aime
beaucoup sur la différenciation je pense
que ça peut commencer par là et ce
serait une belle mise en oeuvre en
l'occurrence sur un sujet qui pourtant
préoccupe l'ensemble de nos élus et les
vérités
par contre on peut dire que Saint-Pierre
et nicloé est un modèle en la matière
puisque tout à fait
[Musique]
parce que nos réalités sont toutes
différentes ce qui fait que sur certains
territoires ce qui vaut sur l'un ne vaut
pas sur l'autre et effectivement chez
nous on a réussi ce traitement des bio
déchets et on espère évidemment que tous
les territoires puissent y passer mais
ça demande des investissements colossaux
ça demande des filières de collecte à
mettre en oeuvre donc ce sont des
thématies des problématiques qui sont
complexes à horizon 2024
bonne fin de journée merci à vous merci
merci